plongez dans un univers obscur ambiance
fin 19e où se côtoient rire et démence
la sphère de la rue de lourcine par la
compagnie matu lui nous emmène sur les
chemins du crime et qui pour quoi
mademoiselle sortait un homme réveil
embrumé pour ses deux comparses qui ont
peut-être la veille au soir commis un
meurtre horrible
commence alors une série de situations
improbables une journée déjanté durant
laquelle ils vont tout faire pour s'en
sortir il ne sent pas une pièce d'eugène
labiche en ambiance on a choisi d'en de
la montée dans la tradition textes et
chants c'est à dire mais vraiment des
boulevards un peu au père est donc on
chante on joue et il ya des morceaux de
chorégraphies à l'intérieur pour en
revenir vraiment à l'essentiel qui est
la version non censurée d'eugène labiche
qui est qui a été fait en 1857 je crois
et qui à l'époque avait été censurée
petite compagnie autonome
ces artistes ont thommen travailler la
musique et les décors en glissant
quelques surprises
on a choisi un décor un peu
traditionnelle mais avec des éléments
proches de notre époque des petits clins
d'oeil que l'on fait aux jeux au film on
a des références comme ça moderne qu'on
a voulu réintégrer dans le cd clin
d'oeil aux spectateurs de trouver comme
comme les personnages de remonter un
petit peu le cours du temps puis de
savoir quels sont les époques les
anachronismes les les petits clins
d'oeil qu'on a glissé à droite et à
gauche dans le dans le décor et puis
dans la mise en scène
il a vendu avant de nommer et soyons
bien certains dans l'une des intrigues
du rire et des comédiens qui n'ont pas
peur de se mouiller pour l'amour du
théâtre ira bien de la justice us la
justice et par ce moyen à ce moyen ne
saura rien
pamiers gonflables et chemise fleurie
qui pique les yeux
la formation tourangelle frankie goes to
pointe à pitre a entamé une série de
concerts de la zouk noise qui fait du
bien aux oreilles sans risquer le coup
de soleil
un livre ce n'est pas que des mots
relier brodé dessinée il peut être
appréhendée pour lui même comme un objet
d'art
c'est tout propos de délire de livres
160 artistes sur le thème si nous y
allions alors allons-y
c'est à la collégiale saint-andré de
chartres c'est l'un des ballets les plus
joués au monde dans le lac des cygnes
les danseurs du prestigieux bolchoï de
minsk nouveau vivre le fol amour du
prince siegfried et de la princesse
odette romantisme en perspective au
zénith d'orléans
et puis bien sûr le coup d'envoi du
printemps de bourges avec des têtes
d'affiché aldebert black m -christine
the queens des découvertes des scènes
gratuites bref du bon son en attendant
de nouvelles idées de sorties dans la
région